hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of the animators react I know
it's been a little while but guess what
we got Alex snow here on the couch with
us today and we're bringing you another
anime episode with one of the craziest
characters I've ever seen
there are some scenes that you're like
is that CG and I think it's moving like
a CG character
that's really meticulous framing there
yeah you can pause on most frames of
this show and go that's a solid drawing
and of course we gotta show Alex our
newest animated Show anime rock paper
scissors too if this is a future or
something stemming from this is the
future what does that look like all of
your favorite shows right here right now
thank you
chainsaw man is he a man-made oh he is
yeah
something like chainsaw man yeah at
first glance appears to be a bunch of
hand-drawn animation yeah but after
watching this show a little bit more
it's like wait a minute I feel I'm
feeling some 3D underneath this yeah
animation like this is 3D animation here
right wait really so I believe if I'm
remembering correctly it's been a bit
since it came out but the main anime is
primarily to the traditional anime I
believe Studio mapa did it and yeah they
do do Jitsu python Attack on Titan or
the later seasons of Attack on Titan I
think they wanted to push how Dynamic
these fight scenes could be and
obviously when you're dealing with
detail work like chainsaws and you know
knife people and monsters and demons but
even in in the CG fight scenes there are
elements of 2D traditional animation
why does he look like a digimon
because he basically had a digimon if
that's true and finds himself inside the
story is what if you ate a digimon
I love how it's directed it's just
really interesting seeing 3D animation
like this incorporated into animation
because I remember when one of the
earlier episodes talking about how you
know Japanese animation were some of the
first animators to approach like rigid
3D objects and hand draw those objects
rotating and preserving their geometry
which is a very complicated thing to do
yeah I mean well we just watched a whole
sequence out with CG or a lot of
elements were and then it literally is
cutting to extremely detailed characters
with complicated movements entirely 2D
animated true and it's interesting to
see where they draw the line or where
they see the advantage of it
[Music]
doing like actual fluid Sims for all the
blood here so I think that's one of the
biggest advantages actually so some of
it is hand drawn but also when it you'll
see him covered in blood
you out here you freak tracking blood is
very hard it's very detailed it's very
small any kind of small detail that you
have to draw is and track is going to be
really difficult for humans and and
everything else so like here when he's
running he's the favorite frame you can
see how hard it is to track the blood in
him here because I think this is hand
drawn now I don't think this is 3D
animation outside of the Chainsaw itself
it's just how the blood's like all over
the place it's hard to tell also I think
there's there could be CG that is then
drawn over yes so there's some scenes
that you're like is that CG and I think
it it's moving like a CG character I
don't think they're pushing the quality
of the movement and posing like they do
when they do 2D when they're drawing it
they're very aware of the poses they're
making and the specific choices they're
making and when they shift to CG it's
about motion it's about it's of course
there's advantages to tracking blood and
things like that but their focus shifts
to look at this cool camera move we can
do and the motion we can have and we can
have them Spin and and do all this
complicated stuff and that's an
advantage you have when you have a model
because it stays more on model and to
the level that most people won't notice
[Music]
also a lot of anime they spend the time
on the pose and you see her talking here
and just the mouth moves so you go okay
I'm gonna spend the time on this and the
movement isn't as important on a shot
like this and then you can spend the
time putting the detail into a dynamic
fight sequence because you've saved the
time and money here while still
maintaining how good the character looks
and they look on model and so that's
difficult when you're like like Nico
said having complicated movements
I go back and forth on chainsaw man I
think they were really successful in
front of a budgetary perspective of what
they were able to create and you know a
couple episodes in you're just like this
is this it becomes a style it's really
cool and what they are able to do
because they took this route I think
they're able to get something unique and
also much more Dynamic and pushed yeah
there's a ton of action there's a ton of
motion there's a ton of design
[Music]
and what a wild show chainsaw man part
man part chain all saw
break from react you know what this is
perfect it's the perfect time to talk to
you about today's sponsor Jesse
he's already know what best he is
they're the most comfortable lightweight
versatile shoe yeah yeah you've already
heard it a million times from me but
what you don't know is that vessi has
trained an AI bot to speak to you from
the quarter crew I thought I'd put it to
the chest what are your favorite type of
bessies
yeah the second most one that we wear is
the weekend shoe and then there's a
storm burst shoe you guys have heard me
promote that one before and I actually
have a pair coming in the mail right now
okay okay fine our Besties
waterproof
okay correct absolutely besties are
designed to be 100 waterproof for the
lifespan of the shoes taking your sock
into a whole new level I literally only
wear Bessie socks they stay dry
next question what are the seeds made
from
veggies are made from a patented
material that's incredibly breathable
which lets you sweat and heat Escape
keeping you fresh all day and they even
know about the awesome Diamond text
material that they're made to work like
magic to keep you warm in the winter and
cool in the summer it's like I'm the one
talking it's like I've heard this all
before
what is the discount code use the
discount code quarter crew to get 15 off
your invested purchase make sure to put
in the code for you to check me out okay
time to say yeah
this is this is me so I mean you you
heard it here first from us just click
the link in the description below or
type investe.com quarter crew to get 15
off of your next vessi purchase
I can I just have a moment with me
I you can get back to your reaction now
he's like you not long for this world
this is the reboot a try gun it was done
by Studio Orange
[Laughter]
what her face turned into a bug and she
her face flew away with the body
attached yeah it's a super cool moment
because that kind of transformation and
and consistency is hard to do in 2D
they're really specific with their shots
and how the characters move it feels
like the best 2D anime
[Music]
that's so cool
in the circle but to your point the
timing of the time is
and it's that ease in you and anticip
your brain goes it's there long enough
that you go why oh it's gonna spin I
spin it and get excited it's it's that
same antic of all my email or one punch
man you know what's coming and then you
get the payoff
but I could feel like the mechanics of
it just like I could see him spinning
the gun yeah he's inside the worm when
he spent the legs right right yeah he
just like falling through a crack he
just created with the laser but it's
it's benefiting from a lot of the CG
elements it's keeping it consistent but
it's it's responsible for every frame
it's animating the characters and the
backgrounds on different frame rates
sometimes which is something uh
spider-verse did sometimes we do it in
2D sometimes you know with more Dynamics
it does feels strobey if you do both but
he's also free to not everything is
specific he's not pulling it around the
the gun is spinning with his hands just
like this we see that on Donatello
because yeah his he just has his hand up
which is okay you know if you do it
right and so you're getting the benefits
and then in other scenes you're able to
do acting at a higher caliber but you
freeze any of these they feel like a
drawing that the attention to detail if
you treat everything like a drawing and
you're utilizing all the benefits from
the tool without just leaning on it
completely I think you end up with
something like this and I think Studio
orange did this extremely impressively
consistently through the series
[Music]
you can pause on most frames of this
show and go that's a solid drawing like
you can with high budget you know anime
that's taking the time like Attack on
Titan or or you know Jiu Jitsu kaisan
and these things where the the effort is
being in there and I haven't really seen
that in one very many CG TV shows in
general but definitely in the anime CG
space It generally feels like they're
just doing it so they can move things
around and this moves things around and
has Dynamic fight scenes but really made
some creative decisions that make this
stand out whether you like the that's
really meticulous framing there yeah
it's very cool that's pretty sweet I'll
check that show out
so this is just a commercial but the
it's done by a studio called the line in
London so this was for the game Marvel
snap and they have the opportunity to do
kind of like almost like Star Wars
Visions those kind of things where you
get to see like multiple styles of very
familiar characters you know they're
they're going going into the history of
comic books and animation and kind of
all art in general to capture these
characters but I thought this was just a
really awesome piece of work with
creativity and the way they're doing the
shots dude I want that card so much I
almost seem it's very static shock uh
yeah it's almost seamless like you just
go from one to the next and like this
one's Scotty young style a very uh
awesome comic book artist but they're
capturing these characters in motion and
styles that we've never really seen
before at a level of detail and Nuance
that's just very cool
first I thought he just lost an arm
foreign
[Music]
it's not just draw it different you know
it's it's a million things coming
together it's a million specific choices
[Music]
I believe they like printed each cell of
this one out to give it a specific oh
dang so they printed it out and then
scanned it just for that like tangible
detail yes you know these guys have such
a respect for art and they generally
animate in a more anime style but their
expertise and their detail are are
pushing it so much beyond that but I
think they had a lot of freedom and and
I think when artists and Studios have
that freedom but these specifics that
must happen it really lets their mind
run wild while also you know getting
those those cork board moments you know
you have to work within your limits and
often the limits are tight it's it's We
Want More For Less faster you know and
that's always the battle you're facing
even if you're capable of creating this
or have the vision for this it's always
a hard balance and and it's really
exciting and I think this space of of
commercial work I think there is room
for exploration there is room for
creativity it's not we have to make 200
million dollars back plus marketing plus
all these things or else you know we're
shutting down tomorrow so it's this
lower risk space that has still brought
extremely talented people some of my
favorite things in cartoons is when you
have like really dark for what the show
is or like really off model or like just
different yeah I can remember various
cartoons I remember an episode of the
Ghostbusters where there's like the
xenobites yeah from Hellraiser in it
what's a cartoon that you remember
having like an oddly dark or like
Twisted Episode uh please leave a
comment down below so you can check them
out on a future episode of animators
react so we're looking at all this anime
stuff I'd love to get your opinion on
our anime rock paper scissors too I'm so
excited
dude that that flame intro I already
love it
[Music]
it was part of my brain that forgot
you're in this
the whole intro segment with music
that's awesome
[Music]
dude that Arrow animation that was cool
so much of this stuff has to be added
after the fact and combined and animated
it's like sure you're generating The
Stills but you got to do something with
a lot of those Stills or I guess movie
sequences in some of these cases like
characters obviously when you say
generate Stills actually I mean it's all
Unreal Engine renders the backgrounds
backgrounds are unreal like 99 of them
like that's all Unreal Engine Unreal
Engine with a stable diffusion rendering
pass right a stylization pass it's like
all the lighting the atmosphere like
that's all from the Unreal Engine it
just goes yeah it just makes it look a
little bit more painted
the jewels because now we go from kid
land back to adult land are you reusing
any footage or are you shooting every
shot original every shot here is assumed
on a green screen okay every single
element only with a true king challenges
me
yeah
sounds like that was moving around Dean
are actually like on an iPhone gimbal on
the green screen and stuff yeah you shot
this anime with an iPhone we shot a lot
with an iPhone yeah any like crazy
sentence that has not been said out loud
shot this anime yeah we shot this anime
with hand stuff let's just do it it just
it can do it it's just doing it every
once in a while like we'll freeze off
apart I was looking there the fingers
are going backwards on the hand there
yeah there's seven fingers yeah I don't
notice too much yeah you don't really
now that was that was attracting coin
right and I was like well limitations
hey I can't do everything like that coin
is not a you know that's not an AI coin
that's just a 3D model with actual it's
a Bitcoin draw an art on it
it's a Bitcoin made out of bits no
further guests allowed tonight King's
orders oh really I mean this one is way
more acting heavy than obviously the
last one yeah and way more characters
yeah the last one had basically two
characters this one has I think seven
props this one has people holding things
the person didn't have any props how are
you dealing with that because holding
props is still annoying in the
traditional CG there's a few ways to do
it it's it's a little bit of everything
like sometimes we're holding it in the
AI translates it and it works sometimes
it's a freeze frame and we just track it
sometimes it's a 3D model tracked in
oh
you're making so many choices here yes
as creators that I would argue are like
more than a normal anime like like
you're making very artistic specific
choices of shots and you know how you're
treating the background and how you're
handling elements you know there's
there's shots that are more like a
storyboard plus and their shots that are
more like live action with a filter on
it like Scanner Darkly so it's it's an
interesting mix and it's interesting to
see look there's so many shots that are
different but it still maintains this
you know the style for the most part and
kind of creates your own style
[Laughter]
his hand is the wrong
don't look at the hand
that's why it's on the edge of the
screen yeah don't look at that
that's a cool shot that's a cool style
that's crazy these are all every shot
is true it's so different but it's
awesome yeah I mean I think it goes back
to you guys like like everyone knows you
from this couch and the things you guys
make and and it's Visa facts heavy and
it's because in the YouTube space you
guys do it better than anyone else and
anyone that says anything else
no but like I think yeah I look at this
for you guys specifically as an
extension of where you guys started like
what whether you like AI whether you're
scared of AI whether it it's it's a big
conversation for sure to have but at the
core of it you guys are our creators and
filmmakers looking to utilize awesome
tools to create what's in your head and
make that a reality at budgets that are
possible and so I think the perception
of you guys is constantly shifting just
as you expand the brand
um I mean our perception of ourselves is
always right you know right and evolving
but I to me like however you feel about
this and I know there's a lot to feel is
at the core of it it's filmmakers
utilizing Tech that's out there to
create content that they have in their
mind and want to bring to life and
hopefully inspires others and also
continues the conversation on if this is
the future or something stemming from
this is a future what does that look
like and how do we find a a way to do
that where everyone's kind of happy and
feeling like it's an extension of the
the craft and skill yeah that's that's I
mean that's a huge conversation is
talking about how does this fit in
because it does empower people yeah but
you know with great power comes great
responsibility yeah
associate how it's evolved since even
the first one and even just to see your
decision making shop or shot of how
you're approaching crowds how you're
approaching backgrounds how to use
Unreal Engine and 3D software in
traditional things like anime is all
even more apparent in this version
compared to the last one which was a
little bit more leaning towards just
kind of this smaller scope of how do we
use this Tech this was like okay now we
kind of know how to use this Tech this
feels like a real episode as opposed to
the other one was more of a proof of
concept right and so it's cool to see
that evolve and and see how you're
pushing it even further well thank you
and thanks for sharing your thoughts
yeah I don't think I said if I liked it
or not specifically there so I tipped it
up it's okay no it's cool
anime rock paper scissors 2 actually
came out just recently if you want to
check it out we'll have a link down
below but it's on our YouTube channel
Corridor that's right we have another
YouTube channel called Corridor it has
more subscribers than this one
I haven't seen a whole lot of anime so
it was wild to see some of this new
stuff I've never heard of Chainsaw man
before that was nuts so thanks for
bringing that to us I'm sorry and you're
welcome
mostly you're welcome yeah mostly you're
welcome thanks for watching see you next
week